I spent an hour playing a really good
game this morning yes it is Tetris not
dissimilar apparently okay we have to
talk about this game right we're not
gonna have any exploiters know when I
have it's kind of impossible well I
don't know I've oh yeah I had that's how
the whole process of trying to figure
out how to like explain certain things
would review talk about them was weird
my knee I was out of those out of
struggle yeah I mean it wasn't like it
wasn't it wasn't too bad it was just
they there was like a list of things we
were supposed to talk about which I was
I looked through my go those all make
sense those are big revelations I came
to on my own but totally how do I
explain why certain puzzles how to
explain how does the game is good
without talking about specific things
and does well it was all like
overarching things because there's so
many great overarching things that
witness does they're also small details
it does really well too all right let's
get into it add Jonathan Blow creator of
2008 breakthrough in d head a Braves was
also featured in indie game the movie
great movie you guys seen it yeah pretty
wonderful documentary yeah he's one of
he is one third of the people involved
in that some of which I've gone on to
release a second game some of which I
haven't he's finally released his new
game it took a couple years Tara it's
called witness it's at today and as a
massive fan of John's work I was very
interested to play and I've played a
little bit this morning and really
enjoyed it Mike you enjoyed it quite a
lot 9 out of 10 on gamespot com for
folks who don't know what the witnesses
or only seen screenshots are think of
who cares it's a puzzle game what is it
about the witness that garnered mine at
a 10 score what makes it so interesting
yeah so you're just you're on this weird
mysterious kind of island and it pretty
much it's just composed of these every
but like a lot of biomes from Earth is
like this autumnal forest there's like a
snowy mountain there's a desert and you
don't know why you're there you don't
know what the purpose of the island is
but it's really weird the first thing
you see is this panel and you just click
your cursor on it drag this glowing line
through we like a line to the end press
X and it opens you go through and it's a
little more complicated and that I mean
it's just a line that turns so it's a
right angle and throughout the game
you're going through these more
increasingly they become mazes and
you're just on these panels and they're
going through these increasingly complex
mazes and like mazes you play as a child
being like your activity book right
where's like star from one point and how
do you get to the middle but they just
sort of keep evolving yeah and it's an
open islands you can go wherever you
want
right away so if you go right toward
this village in the middle and you see
these really complicated puzzles you'll
have no idea what your [ __ ] to do at all
I mean you theoretically there's
probably like a 1 in 10,000 chance you
can get lucky and do the right path but
odds are that won't happen but if you go
to certain other areas it does it's a
really one of the better uses of
open-world structure I can think of in
like recent memory because it's it's a
really hard game it's challenging you
can open any of the solve any these
puzzles from the get-go it's just you're
pretty much going around the island and
acquiring the knowledge necessary
there's no hidden keys like sounds
really try and annoying and cliche but
like you know the knowledge is the key
like you have to learn how to do certain
things in order to progress and there
are certain symbols and the mazes and
it's crazy how well the game keeps you
invested in learning the new rules
because it seems boring at first like a
lot of people are so someone exactly
like we're looking at this gameplay you
don't have like the sort of you know the
people watching don't know anything
about what any of this stuff means like
we're just drawing around boxes and
smells like that i was playing this
morning i think the easiest sort of
thing to combine it too is i remember
playing brave and like you'd see video
of like the later levels and braid and
be like what the hell is going on like
he's moving and then the thing is moving
and then he picks up the key with his
shadow version and he's got it just
looks crazy but if there's one thing
Jonathan Blow really achieved at that
game is that he managed to communicate
these incredibly complex mechanics
really well and in the first like
whatever hour and a half i plated this
game there are puzzles that I had seen
in the Australian that I that I got
stuck out while I was playing that now
they make complete sense and in a weird
way they sort of attack they're sort of
like they're familiar in a strange way
where like they feel like you know
you're walking in the street you're like
trying not to step on the cracks you
know and you're like you're maybe
driving then the the road and you're
sort of make I suggesting right squeeze
my toes when when cars came down against
me and the traffic I'd squeeze my toes
whenever when there was a car passing
and then I wouldn't I'd release my toes
like these things that they feel like
subconscious games that we always play
like in a weird way these games are
those and they're so satisfying when you
like when you solve them yeah I used to
have like really bad manifestations of
OCD when I was like light switches and
certain patterns i would do I was like
clicking my tongue when I was just
sitting there yeah there's a lot of
these things I'm sure there's a ton of
series of people are gonna dig into like
what does this symbol represent because
you know you could talk about any story
present game later without spoiling it
but yeah there's like you'll immediately
learn the one he showed in a lot of
histon his demos I like III or GDC at
those surprise demos he did you know
that you see these white and black black
blocks and it'll start off I guess it's
the equivalent of a tutorial you'll do
the first panel it's really simple just
one line directly through the black and
white bunks the next one there's two
white boxes in one black and you kind of
figure out half the game and the fun of
the game is figuring out what it's
telling you yeah and the easy part is uh
like applying those skills it's really
just figuring out how what it's telling
you because like you know you talk to
other people and really what does this
symbol mean I still can't figure it out
like there's a flux capacitor symbol
that shows up later that's my favorite
one again I won't go into but I was
talking to bread at Giant Bomb oh my god
what's going on over here yeah we've
been talking about certain like how to
do certain puzzles and then it's crazy
how we're like did you figure this one
out yet or did you kind of figure out
what that matter what that was telling
you it's really it's really fun talking
other people and I walked by your screen
today yeah and you were on one and it's
funny cuz looking back it's you don't
really remember the specific path you
know I really have to be in the moment
know what the last puzzle you did was I
was complete I did not know what to do
in that puzzle at all when you were over
near me and then like I just got it yeah
like I just looked the space there
there's also an element of you sort of
there's exposition happening in the
world without getting it to do those of
yeah they talks about things like you
know meta physics and science and faith
and stuff and I came across one of tho I
just have another and then if like it
was this late this I heard basically
some stuff about faith and about God and
how God both is invisible and not
visible depending on how you're thinking
about it and that made me solve the
puzzle yeah it sounds it sounds to hear
you say that and like a lot of when
you're actually listening to them they
sound really preachy and you know the
yeah the initial thing is to say you
know Indians man yeah like Jonathan Blow
doing this thing again but it's really
it's great how the game it doesn't hold
your hand at all it communicates
everything really subtly and a trust
that you are patient and intelligent and
you're willing to try to read into
everything possible because there are
clues everywhere they're clues
in the island they're clues in the way
it tells its story there are clues in
the way you know certain puzzles
progress and it's it's that was one of
my favorite things how how it
communicates so much but actually tells
you very little directly I want to kind
of ask a couple of questions that are
going to be a little bit more boring and
mechanical yeah but I feel like there's
a lot of people have a sort of on
Twitter's when it feels like a lot of
people who are like not sure if they
want to buy this because it's a puzzle
game and probably because of the price
tag as well it's a forty-dollar game and
is he I still feel like people are a
little bit reticent to jump in on
something like this when it's so
abstract so just get some stuff that it
away how hard is this game was it did it
feel safe hard like were you stuck on a
puzzle for really long and did it kill
you or was it was the payoff worth it
like what's the difficulty like in the
witness it's very very very challenging
but that is I don't this might turn some
people off but that is part of the charm
not charm that's part of the actual
overall experience because it's very
much a game you could come back to the
next day and you'll see something that
you got stuck up on for like 60 minutes
or some other people I talked to plate
it kept coming back to the same puzzle
throughout their whole playthrough and
couldn't figure it out and I had that
same one it was it was one of the
earlier ones I couldn't figure out it
was like the last in the sequence of a
new rule set you had to learn right and
I could not figure it out forever and
then I kept talking someone could figure
it out like do not tell me but it's
failing me and I finally and I progress
a lot through the rest of game and that
was the one thing I needed to do this
other big thing oh my god I I'm gonna
have to ask somebody but then I was like
now you know what and then I saw one
little things like are you kidding me
this last 20 hours that's what I was
missing and it sounds like it's
frustrating it does get frustrating a
lot it's mentally exhausting game
there's no doubt about that at all for
me it was but if you stick through it
and really just trust that you can go
across the island and use that
open-world structure to drop one thing
go over to the desert if you can't
figure things out on the beach there
will be something in the desert or in
the forest or in the castle that that's
like something off that's like a
motivational poster like go off to the
desert if you can't figure out the beach
just pay it no but that's that's what
the moment felt like as well from it
does it is that what a [ __ ] cuz i only
paid over short man talking but it felt
very much like dude I want to be playing
this in a dark room on my own for like
six like
it felt like was invalid me in this
experience is I would feel like the
thread a thread it's I was talking to
other people that played it's it's one
of those games I it's been a long time I
hate using like hyperbole in any sense
when I'm talking about like how much I
think about a game cuz you know about it
I think it can become kind of cliche to
say I thought about this game for weeks
after I finished it that's that's cool
if a game can do that but I really have
said that method I'm sure I do think
with other streams no but like you
you'll start it's just one of those
things like if you're if you're writing
something long or if you're like a
musician and you're trying to write like
I president tell you like you're writing
a song or something and you're kind of
even when you're not doing your thinking
about it like this game is one of those
things where I would still think about
how I could use this symbol in
conjunction with this even when I didn't
want to think about it wasn't like I
need to get back to the game it was more
just like it it kind of just challenges
how you think when you step back into it
because it is very very challenging but
and I love difficult games I love like
Miyazaki's games I loved like the old
school I still play the old school
Megaman sometimes not that those are
hard in the same sense but this is
really really one of the more rewarding
games I've ever like beaten and beating
it is a weird term i mentioned this in
the review because there are a lot of
different ways it can kind of unfold and
he said that you can spend 90 hours
playing this game which that's another
cool thing you play for about five hours
and like I don't see how this could last
90 hours and then you find this one
layer of the game itself structurally
you're like oh my god that's another 20
hours right there and they're like the
finish you get farther and I like tiny
though you see one more thing oh my god
that I had no idea that happened it
completely it keeps changing how you see
the game as a whole a really cool thing
so every time you see something smaller
like that's probably a huge deal that I
don't even want to try to wrap my brain
around right now because I'm still
trying to figure out this whole thing
which somehow connects to this but yeah
it's just the more you have these
revelations on so many different levels
as you're playing through it and it's
it's a it's a really cool experience as
a whole but also in its detail did you
ever play Fez yeah really yeah and
that's actually something else that I
had been telling a few people I was like
don't think of it as braid think of it
more as a fez not like his you know Fez
you're like has its own language you at
translate if you really want to get into
it this I guess this whole game is doing
that
very i think this does a better job of
communicating those fez some of those
things were really opaque it seems like
i feel like in 2016 all the feds hasn't
been uncovered yet it's like one of
those things he keep hearing up a couple
of months oh we just figured out this
other yeah just as a sidebar we don't
talk about Fez enough ain't right
brilliant yeah even if phil fish maybe
should keep his mouth shut yeah his own
good I don't mind him but man that game
was special yeah and I did I get the
same thing that you're telling me from
the witness yeah it's hard for me to sit
here you were asking me earlier am I
gonna play I was like am I gonna find
the time you know it's like I have to
like right choice yes it's it's a very I
think it's important game for a few
reasons which you can get into in
another conversation but yeah it's very
much like fez and that the forty dollar
price tag is completely like spend forty
dollars in scam it's very well worth it
I think it's worth more than forty
dollars but what kind of deal say really
would haha yeah what you see the
pre-order bonuses a warm fuzzy feeling
the game also i am i wrong I i looked at
the steam achievements and it has one
but not anna has one and has one hidden
one its 01 is complete the game and the
second one is something else that you
won't know unless you unlock it no there
was more with the the ps4 the debugger
playing i'm staying on pc there are
certain trophies for a company because
like again the game you start to realize
what your overarching objectives are
right and you get a trophy for each of
those at least in the person we have
yeah i have to look into that because I
wonder if steam doesn't fall you might
have changed since it released fully
because again we have like a pre-release
yeah maybe so many forces people i don't
know what I baby i love to look internet
I got a couple of questions here yes mr.
Vic says can you ask Mike how hard that
one puzzle was that supposedly only one
percent of players can pass so here's
the thing i don't know which one he's
talking about that is there are three
alright so i think there are something
like 650 or 700 total puzzles right when
i beat the game we got the soft ending
as I called it I solved about 400 oh so
there are a bunch that I haven't solved
uh the one that I think he's talking
about it's not even that it looks hard
when you first look at it but the more
you try it the more you realize how many
permutations are preventing you from
solving it and there are certain rules
to it that I still don't exactly know
and there's this one series of puzzles
that I'd love watching people or the two
people I've watched after I figured it
out
but it just it makes you think about
every single other puzzle now in
different gosh yeah it's like I was
watching you today I was like if he
knows this thing these would be so easy
right now but it's uh I had if it's the
puzzle I think it is I don't see myself
ever finishing it not my goodness yeah
all right reviews up on gamespot com
right now and 9 out of 10 yeah oh add es
porque CH d makes a good point can't
wait to see Soulja Boy's review oh ok
somebody he wrote here your eyes roll
back so far they might have come out of
your arse there I yeah i'm looking
forward to yeah playing more the witness
looking for is having people talk about
it as well yeah also it doesn't seem
like the type again is it the last point
is this the type of game that somebody
could spoil by saying a sentence because
it seems like so much of the spoilers
know are very abstract so she would be
worried about being in comments or no so
when i say there's a story it's it's
just how the themes is telling there's
no there's not from what i've seen
there's not like a narrative payoff
right so no I couldn't but I get spoiled
like how to do certain puzzles but even
then it wouldn't really affect it you
don't like open a door and in the Kaiser
Soze is there yeah this big just becomes
frog fraction to exactly there you go
alright thanks Mike my hearty thank you
so much coming in telling us all about
the witness and let us know if you
excited are you excited for the witness
and those the forty dollars play a part
and in your purchasing decision add you
like hard games hard puzzle games let us
know in the comment box below